S
ALL THREE SENATORSING
MSYER
VACCIN SND
TH FOX IS "OUTFRONT" FOR US L A
TH D.NCED THEIR POSITIVE TEST ON
WHAT MORE ARE
TONIGHT?
>> Reporter: I THINKNEACTOR HERN
, ANGUS  INDEPENDE,  HICKENLPE .
AND  THIS  RST TIMEVE
FULLY VACCINATED SENATOR T THEYD
JUST COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, WE
GRAHAM FROCARO NOUNCEME. WD OR
CO FM.T ONE THING P  MIND,
ITG AG
S ARE ON RECESS RIGHT
OF DAYAGO,HAT THEY WERE L
ONFOR THIS VOS
SERS TO BE CSEOG
SOMEG MASKS, SOME
BUT ONEEP IN MIND,
THESE SENATORS, IN ORK WITH C
CONSTITUTSHER,
ABOUT OTOUND A LF FOR NGING THAI
FROMD HICKENOPER, THEY
WERE ARGUING THIS IS
AND ENCOURAGEMEN.
BECAUSE ONE WAY TO REAY REDU
BACK HOME ANCOJUST MSURE MORE
KATE?
NK YOUS DR.
WHHONDER REINER, HE ADVISED THE
PRESIDENT THRESENATORS, ONR,G T
LLW IF
CONNECTED OR NOT.
BUT  DOES FOE
RE OF US
>>ELST O I MORE THAN LI
DEMOCRAT, T, ANVIS N'T CARE.T CA
I AK ICS AREVIRUDOCARE WHETHER T
WICKER IS D KING INATO AUT0 ORA
77.
KLDOPLE,
ANTIBODY RPO
AS ROBUST AS FOR Y PEGE.
ALSO, WE KNOW THAT
SENATORS
FIRST WAVE.SOVEN BEGNI
WHAT WE'RE LEAIN O
EFFECT OF THE VACCINESANE.
STORM.ER PEOPL IAT T, THAT'SER
PEOPLE WITHOUT ON.NG TO
T BREAHR
ED DURRVALHES THE SEFOTEULD BEE.
WHETHER HENDY
HAVETER BOOSTELE W BOOSTER SHOT.
SHOTS ALL THE WAY N,
SO IT'S PAST TIME. PRESIDENTS 7H
GOTTENHIYET?LDK TH THE T
RA
THE PRESIDENT OF
STATES HAS ARITY A
EQUIRES.TRAVELS AROUD HE H SECR
HIM.
HE'S 7YEARS OL